so from the moment you did the
documentary which went viral and was
shared by everybody around the world I'm
sure a lot of people contacted you a lot
of different people tell us sending
their own stories here's what I know
here's what I know what's changed from
the stories and the document in which by
the way you're a general Spaulding there
yeah Gordon xiangu you have dr. Judy my
kibbutz there which is how I saw and
found out about dr. judy was through
your document I believe you were one of
the first ones in the last you know
during this era of the China and
coronavirus that we heard about dr. judy
where other people have been now
interviewing her what's changed from
seeing the documentary from China to
today
well since the documentary was released
there have actually been a lot of
reports corroborating what we've said
you know there of course now
investigations is going into it
specifically on individuals that we
directly point to such as this dr. Shi
jangly this Batwoman of China as being
one of the possible central figures in
this entire thing the u.s. is launching
multiple investigations I just reported
for example they cut they cut funding to
an NIH program that was going to China
dr. Jia that's it sorry this dr. Shi
generally is actually named in some of
the reports on that there was a Pentagon
program that was also you know it's
being investigated right now sending
money to China other ones
many of them are mentioning dr. Shi
generally there's investigations into
some of the US universities such as in
Texas and also again naming directly dr.
Shi gently and this Wuhan Institute of
biology and so it does appear that we at
the very least contributed some evidence
that may be helping some of these
investigations we'll have to see and of
course a lot of media came out after we
published the video doing interviews
such as for example Washington Post had
a had an article noting that in 2018
there were State Department cables
warning of security problems at that
laboratory more articles like that have
come out there have been some other ones
exclusives and other media really just
corroborating what we said as well so
what is your biggest concern what's your
biggest comes from with China today
you're right you were so
deep into it what's your biggest concern
so when when it comes to the way I view
the Chinese regime it's maybe a bit
different from a lot of how a lot of
people view it the Chinese regime
regards the United States as its
number-one enemy the very existence of a
country that you know is based on the
ideas of say individual rights does
defend internationally to some extent
human rights does believe in this idea
that if given basic freedoms people can
create a prosperous society these things
are antithetical to the narratives and
the practices of the Chinese Communist
Party it tells people that they are not
capable of creating a harmonious and
functioning society if people are given
freedom like we have here and so
challenging that attacking the United
States undermining this perception is a
huge part of what the Chinese regime is
doing and when it comes to their systems
of warfare of course when we think war
normally we think tanks guns soldiers
you know jets missiles these kinds of
things when you're dealing with the
Chinese Communist Party they're talking
about culture they're talking about
drugs they're talking about business
warfare cyber they're talking about the
basic perceptions things like they have
a three Warfare's doctrine psychological
warfare media warfare and legal war fur
how do you how do you alter
international perceptions of issues how
do you manipulate the say basic
perceptions of a country in order to
support or oppose what they want you to
support a repose
you
[Music]